Benji didn't wear a coat to work here we
go he's wearing a t-shirt
Benji aren't you cold no when I was a
kid I did think it looked like cool I
thought it was like really uncool to
wear coat or okay but now this is the
true answer I would love to get a winter
coat
I have trouble deciding which coat to
buy they see that sounds silly to me
it's not a joke and it can't go to a
store so your coat Eli combined it's
because I'm I want to get the perfect
one and that's with a lot of things in
my life like this I don't know I agree
that that is a all right okay thank you
didn't I give you a coat last year and I
wear it what happened to that um it was
a beautiful coat and it just um there
was another guy that works with us that
that uh it fit better and I gave it to
him
all right thanks did you ever get a
wallet or used to walk around that
plastic bag full of money I had a
problem with the plastic bag I go to a
12-step meeting you would have a dress
that means for eating a free Overeaters
Anonymous and uh it's so supportive it's
a good how's that going to you losing
weight so I was in a meeting and
someone's like what they pass a bag to
collect money for rent for the room put
it in like two or three dollars and
someone goes where's the bag and I just
didn't really pay attention to somebody
so they said it again like the treasurer
where's the bag then also oh my god I
pocketed the bag by mistake because it's
a plastic bag I got confused I thought
it was my wallet but I had to pull out I
was like look I have two bags I'm really
sorry
right and they laughed they believe me
but so I did start after that I started
using a couple years ago Wendy got me a
wallet and I started using that one all
right
fascinating he confused his plastic bag
with the bag they were passing well
Thank You Benji fascinating you put what
I do wrong not they not be in other
words I we just wanted to hear if you
had a wallet and I heard it now I'm done
yeah that's it now go outside and freeze
what is it Jason I have a weird Benji
update go ahead he was just seen right
before he came in here drinking salsa
straight from the can well very straight
from the
why would you do that how the ovaries
anonymous has to tell you that that's
not good for you in terms of calories
even no no that was just because I had
salsa and I was just but why would you
drink that straight through it's not
even good I wasn't drinking it I was
eating it
alright thanks thanks whatever your name
is Jason Wow
he's a guy going over he's anonymous
he's shrinking out about salsa kebab